all right guys all right basically the
city celebrating Halloween yeah I am
celebrating Halloween right also
celebrating superheroes superheroes okay
that's good that's a friend there
this is Robin Robin hey Robin without
robbing everybody needs a Robin yes
when you only drive in the car yeah
exactly everybody's a little help that's
good I'll spell great here and do you
believe in God run with the logical back
chocolate Batman yeah call me back okay
Batman I'm Ally
yeah hi Alice I believe in one supreme
power well and omnipotent power that's
amazing okay all right
so we're the same chapter then okay okay
so you do not believe that for example
any man is God or a statue of God or
tree is God you just believe God is the
powerful he does not belong to his
creation is that I believe God God is
omnipotent but that's that's amazing
basically first we're Muslims
yeah we believe we've been in one
creature as well so we'll just come
either we'll just talk about our
religion because you know our religion
but you know a lot of people about
misconceptions about it okay so you do
believe ago so you've done that job for
me I don't need to go around we we
believe in the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and we believe in all the
messengers that came before before him
as well do you believe in scriptures
revelations or do you say I don't kind
of go into the I'd rather go for but the
people who have come in the past and
left a message okay okay so you do
because the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he came that 1400 years ago
yeah and he brought the Quran right and
so to be honest to the people that kind
of say you know what look are I can't me
from God
there's proofs inside the Quran but for
example the Quran challenges the people
that for example if you mean I'm not
sure what verses but I said if you think
the Quran is a not from God if you think
this is not from your Creator
bring a verse like here so it's doing an
open challenge the people that are
saying look this is not from God it's
clearly telling you look if you think
this is not from your Creator bring a
verse like it not only that has got many
scientific miracles I don't use her
the Klan is talking about in biology the
expansion of the universe the two seas
meets about they do not transgress so
this is a there's many things that a man
cuz Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
was he didn't know he did not have to
read or write do you get on transit so
so we need to ask yourself how could a
man 1400 years ago where there's no
technology he comes along with this kind
of message right how does he do it
because there's so many stuff in that is
just it's impossible for him to know
such things right so what I would say is
for example that you know when
everything we buy we have a product
right that will buy a product everything
comes with a menu right it tells us how
to use the product right otherwise we
wouldn't know that for example if if
somebody just invented the television
new and you and I bought a telly but you
didn't know how to use it you can never
make it work right because it comes with
a guidebook so what we see is if God
made us he should have sent a revelation
to tell us how to live our lives because
he made us he knows what's good for us
and what's bad for us right so we would
say that you know okay as everybody else
has a product as a man you we humans
have the revelation to tell us how to
live our lives
do you understand one thing I think that
yeah is if you wish to live your life by
that manual then you should add a to the
manual you have not only use the manual
when you want and then do something
except that you know what exactly your
hundred percent right than that it's
you're right there's a lot of people out
there that you know even cushions they
say we're Christians but they don't
practice their religion properly there's
a lot of Muslims that that they say
they're Muslims they don't practice of
religion properly but you're right 100
percent right
is there any kind of misconception that
you wanna know about Islam or cuz you
don't have the media portrays us is
anything that you wanna I can clarify
yeah well guys like I have tried to
clarify and that's the word of jihad
which is a personal battle against the
darkness in yourself that I understand
that's not against other worldly human
beings is misinterpretation that's
dedication
yes no you know I know it's really happy
because the things that I don't even
explain just like you said the words you
had this two meanings for it right so
dad is for example striving right for
example I can struggle to for example
let's say I
was an alcoholic before right I said you
know what I'm gonna stop drinking
alcohol so what it is is jihad within
yourself to stop doing that do you get
to tell your fighter within yourself to
stop doing that another way of jihad is
fighting but how's it fighting if the
enemy comes to attack you which is
called self-defense right so it's
protecting yourself you know your
friends here yes he came to attack you
so yeah yeah like I said so would it be
any fun it was there be any reason of
you saying you know what I like I won't
believe I can't believe that the Quran
is from God is anything that's in your
head that you can say you know what I've
got doubts of this or that no I would
challenge the Quran the Quran is a
system of belief that many people live
by and I know this is very good in its
true state years I wouldn't same as I
wouldn't challenge the Bible therefore
the Torah none of course but we do would
you believe that the God Almighty will
send down messengers yeah I think we all
messages above well no we're we're all
sons of God we are okay yeah okay we are
some people have put that message
forward a lot louder and clearer love
course because maybe they make more
sense yeah of course like for example
I'm conveying a message to you you're
right in that manner but chosen
messengers like from God saying you know
what this is you're the chosen one these
are the revelations view I send down so
do you believe in them or okay let me
explain idea I think what sahaja yoga
meditation and sahaja yoga to meditation
believes that each chakra that you have
yeah is really related to a different
prophet okay so here the big center
that's Muhammad's chakra the big green
one in the center of your body okay your
throat is krsna's chakra and in your
head is the Christ chakra
okay and I like that way of explaining
how everyone is related okay okay so
when he said like the stomach bit so
what how do you refer that to Prophet
Mohammed so how does it work well
because it's it's a large huge expense
they color it green in the instagrams
and yeah and that's the way they like to
explain it this is related to Mohammed
the instructor is doing extra kushner
and this chakra is related to price okay
so is that is that the belief that said
interpretation is a stage of the Hajj or
yoga meditation sahaja yoga Burnett okay
all right so but about if we say okay if
we say the revelation was sent by God
right now if I could prove that to you
wouldn't you say you know what let me
take my time out and read the Quran
maybe like I have you ready to put on
the phone I have very bit a little bit
of it okay all right so is there any
reason that you can doubt that like
message it's not just as we as you know
I'm coming in a message like you said
every day so you would say that you do
excel again when we talk about
realization self-realization as you say
says that you make sure the words of
realization yeah that's when you get the
messages that's when you're when you
become a realized soul in yourself yeah
through spiritual practice okay through
a good work
yeah through controlling yourself then
then you will find that unlike them in
yourself and your message might be
different okay okay yeah yeah that's
true
but I'm gonna leave you because you're
at your working but you have read the
Quran a bit I have read I would advise
you to give it a chance by you know read
it all you know read order that end day
we all gonna die yeah we all that
believe me
my own mother who loves me so much is
not gonna come integrate with me so I
respect your views and a lot of things
we agree on and stuff like that I like
that cuz you believe in one good because
we say look God cannot be human because
some Christians believe that Jesus is
God himself so you know it's a bit wrong
because nowhere in the Bible Jesus
claimed divinity never said I am gonna
worship Me
and it's really great you believe but
well say I don't hold you much give it
to put on a chunk I'll read it and
inshallah it was really nice talking to
you have a nice day Robin have a nice
day the cost is it easy or that my
brother is your brother yeah okay